Fans have a close relationship with their
favorite shows. But sometimes, those shows
let us down, and they actually have to apologize
for doing us wrong. Here are a few that had
to say they were sorry to mend our broken
little hearts.
Chuck Lorre for Two and a Half Men
Two and a Half Men had enough of an audience
to last for 12 seasons, but no one ever made
the mistake of confusing it with quality TV.
Not even the show's co-creator Chuck Lorre.
At the 2014 Television Academy Honors, Lorre
won an award for his latest show, Mom, and
used his speech to apologize for bringing
it into the world at all:
"To do a show about people trying to redeem
their lives and to salvage and repair the
damage they've done, well, for me that's an
opportunity to apologize for Two and a Half
Men."
Hmmm. Apology...not accepted.
Dan Harmon for Community
The cult sitcom Community seemed to be constantly
embroiled in trouble during its six-season
run. In an effort to alleviate some of the
tension, NBC fired creator and showrunner
Dan Harmon.
"Buenos dios, children!"
After fans protested and ratings dropped,
the network brought Harmon back. In celebration,
the embittered Harmon publicly trashed the
episodes filmed without him. Not cool.
Harmon quickly wrote a very long apology directed
towards the show's fans, actors, and crew,
saying, "Even if my goal had been to hurt
someone, it would never have been you."
Chris Evans for Top Gear
When Top Gear lost all three of its popular
hosts after Jeremy Clarkson's infamous punch-drunk
assault of the show's crew, the BBC scrambled
to keep its top-rated show running with new
hosts and new gimmicks. Unfortunately, one
of those gimmicks included doing donuts around
a respected war memorial, Whitehall's Cenotaph.
The stunt was quickly called out by veterans
before the show even got to air. New host
Chris Evans apologized, saying he and the
crew were "mortified," and promised that shots
of the memorial would be cut out before the
show made it to air. Good idea.
Everyone on Star Trek: The Next Generation
for “Code of Honor”
Watching the third episode of Star Trek: The
Next Generation is enough to leave you astonished
that the show actually made it through a single
season. "Code of Honor" portrays a backwards
vision of a tribal space-Africa. While the
episode attempts to deliver a message about
accepting different cultures, it misses spectacularly,
falling into blatant racism and sexism.
"Yar is to become my First One."
"I challenge your right of supersedence!"
"No woman has challenged supersedence for
over two hundred years!"
"The right is mine, and I will have it."
At different times, almost everyone involved
with the show has apologized for its existence.
Actor Jonathan Frakes stated that Trek creator
Gene Roddenberry would have been embarrassed.
Actor Brent Spiner remarked that the show
never got "quite that bad again," and Michael
Dorn simply called it "the worst ever filmed."
Robert Kirkman for The Walking Dead season
6 finale
For The Walking Dead comic fans, Negan is
the ultimate villain, and the entire TV series
was a buildup to the moment that his barbed-wire
bat came down on a beloved cast member's dome—a
moment they were cheated out of when the show
cut to black at the end of season 6:
"You can breath, you can blink, you can cry.
Hell, you're all gonna be doing that."
Fans were enraged at the cliffhanger, prompting
creator Robert Kirkman to apologize in the
letters page of The Walking Dead #154. Sort
of.
"For some of you, [the cliffhanger] backfired
and you're angry. And for that I'm sorry."
It’s not much of an apology, but it's better
than nothing. Thanks?
And thank you for watching! Subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos like
the one you just saw. And leave us a comment
to let us know which TV shows you think owe
us all an apology...